Do you think ultimately religion
is good for human civilization?
Let me maybe phrase it differently is what's religion good
for.
Okay. Yeah. That's a great question.
Thanks for asking that most people don't ask that.
And I think it's the question to ask, why do we still have religion?
That's the question, right? Because scientists and others scholars,
um,
humanists even thought that there's this thing called the
secular secularization thesis. And it's this idea that the more, um,
we progress rationally and we have better instruments for understanding our
reality, the less religious we will be, but that's been found to be untrue.
We're still very religious. Okay. So why, why is it around? Well,
it's adaptive in some way, in my opinion,
most many people would not agree with me,
but I kind of see it as an evolutionary adaptation.
Now think about religions. Okay. Think about Christianity again for one.
Um,
here comes this idea when you have this ruthless empire called the Roman empire,
which litters its its roads with crucified bodies to let
you know don't mess with us. Okay. All right here.
All of a sudden you have this guy saying God is love. Okay. All right.
Well that's weird. Okay. So why, why does this take off? Well,
it takes off because we're becoming a, um,
a colonial power. That means we're going into other countries.
We're conquering them. We are, you know,
how do we survive together as,
as cultures that don't clash? Well,
we have to have a belief structure that allows us to,
and I think religion function that way.
So religions help us from also Richard
Dawkins me, my DIA.
It allows us to explore space of ideas. Um,
and that in itself is the, um,
so it's like evolution of ideas and which is a powerful tool for
us to explore ideas.
You know, if, if I believe that men have souls,
do they? Yes, they do.
Well.
I'm trying to figure that out. Why still,
in terms of souls do believe cats don't have souls, but we'll never,
we'll never, we'll never be able to confirm that.
Maybe if we get better instruments, you know, the sole instrument,
you need to come up with that one, please. Yeah. Not just for cats,
but for all animals and people in general, you can put them in like a little,
you know, sole machine and find out what's the status of their soul.
That's funny. I hope will become a scientific of consciousness.
And consciousness is in some sense connected to maybe what the meaning
of the word soul used to be.
And I think it's a fascinating open question. Like what is cautious and so on,
maybe we'll touch on, uh, in a little bit, but yeah. Anyway, back to her.
Religions being adaptive, I think that Christianity probably helped us, um,
become better people to each other.
As we moved into a more global society.